じゃあ心素は五十二種類ありますということも言いましたね
そこでこの感断というのは
人間の感情といったっても
動物の感情といっても
ありとあらゆることたくさんありますけど
仏教では全部考えて この基本的な感情は何ですかと
それだけまとめてやるんですね
いわゆる私たちから見ても
もう 例えば我々はもう何かを認識して腹が立つ
何かを認識してすごい気持ちよくなる
何かを認識して嫉妬する
何かを認識してまた悔やんだりするとかね
そういうのはもう決まっているようなものなんです
生命には ですから すべての生命に
まあこの五十二種類のことしか起こりえませんというふうなことなんですね
その五十二も悪い心素
いわゆる悪ですか 不善ですか
不善心素と善心素に分けていて
その中でもそういう善も不善とも言えない
ろくはたらきのみの心素と
だいたい三つに分けているんですね
例えば怒りといったら
まああれは良くないとごくすぐもうわかっちゃうし
例えば怒りの感情で行動すると
その生命にはろくな結果は得られないんですね
ですから 生命の不幸に至る不幸をもたらす感情は不善だと
生命の幸福をもたらす感情は上心性善心性だと二つに分ける
別に苦福不幸と関係なく
どうせ生まれる感情をまた違うカテゴリに入れていて
そういうふうな それはこれからそういうカテゴリごとに一つ一つ
あの これからの説明なんですけど
これはどれぐらい時間がかかるかとは分かりませんですけど
三番目の集義体はルーパですね
ルーパといって こちらの定義はすごい簡単です
これ定義にならない定義なんですけど
これは ルーパというのは色
このテキストには定義が抜けちゃったみたい
このルッパティという動詞がありまして
だいたいサンスクリット語
パーリ語っていうのは動詞ばっかりなんです
名詞っていうのはもう全部強引に作ったものなんです
ですから この漢文とは違うんです
漢文は名詞ばっかして動詞は強引に作ってるんですね
で 算数系はもう全部動詞
動詞から名詞作る で ルッパティっていうのはこの変化するっていう意味なんです
変化するんだからルーパというんですと
こちらちょっと一つ間違いがあります
もうまだ間違いいっぱい
すいません 特異的がローカル
ルッパティっていうのは変化する
変化するんだからルーパと言うんですよと
そうするとなんか日本語でわからないようになりますけど
パーリ語で考えると ああなるほどというルッパティ
変化するという意味です
ルーパと だからルーパと言えばすぐ変化するもので理解しなくちゃいけない
いわゆる変わるものという意味なんですね
すぐ変わってしまっちゃうものというふうな意味なんです
ああ じゃあ話戻りますけど
今まで我々は何で生命かというと
認識するんだから生命の誕生であって
別に生命というものがあるわけじゃないんです
仮に世俗体で生命と言うんです
なぜならば そこに認識機能が働いているんだから
で 認識機能というものも認識しなきゃもうないんですね
そうでないと ただ理論論理だけになっちゃいますから
ですから 認識するという機能はずっと絶えず続けているし
そこで我々が仮に言葉借りで世俗体として生命というだけのことで
このみんな生命は何ですか
生命の誕生はいつですかとか
そういうくだらないことを考えているのは
このそこら辺がわかってないだからなんですね
生命があるんだと もう世俗体は正義体で勘違いしてて
そのあるんだと思っている生命はどこにあるんだとまた探してるんですね
哲学を考えてください
魂があるんだとまず決めちゃうんですね
決めちゃったらそれで終わりはずなのに
その魂がどこにあるか
また で ヨーロッパ的な考え方を見ても
神様に創造されたと 言うならばそれで問題終わりでしょうに
それで神様は存在す どういう存在を何とかして出そうと
それから探すんですね
本当に神様は存在するかしないかと
だからいくら経っても彼らにはもう同じところでぐるぐる回るだけで答えが出てこないんですね
ヒンドゥー教でも同じことの魂はあるんだと
アーツマンがあるんだと
あるんだと決めちゃったらそれで終わりでしょうに
そこでそのアーツマンはいかなるものかと
また考えちゃう ですからもう全くもう
もう なんて言いますか
迷路の中に入っちゃって
いつでも間違っているところで曲がったり曲がったりしている
同じところでぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるんですね
すべての手すりにお釈迦様が言ってるのは
こういうこの人 全部一緒につながっている網の中みたいに
その中でみんないちいち歩いて歩いて
歩いて どこへ行ってもまあもう逃げ道が見つからない
ということなんですね
で 我々が知っている大乗仏教も同じことを同じ過ちを犯してるんですね
絶対やってはいけない過ちを
仏教だったら だから すごい失礼な言葉で言うならば
大乗仏教は全く仏教ではないんです
それは日本の学者は昔はね
もう大乗は仏教に荒すという概念まで作っちゃって
研究まですいていたんだから
叩かれたんだけどね でも決して学問的に正しく叩かれたわけではなくて
感情であんた何言ってるんで
大乗仏教は仏教だよと
また研究はまた発展しましただけで
でもやっぱり魂があるんだという概念から大乗仏教が始まりますから
魂という言葉も使わない
骨身があるんだとか なんか実体があるんだ
あるんだと言ったならば
それで終わりですから
問題は 考える必要も何もないんだから
なんでそれから考えるんですかね
結論はもう最後に来るものであって
この人々はまず結論出して
この結論はどうやってもう成立するかと
ベリファイするかと頑張ってるんですね
おかしいことなんですね
仏教は逆に小講に よって結論を考えるんであって
結論は最初からは作ってわかないんですね
その話を置いておいて
生命というのは認識することなんですね
認識するといろんな感情が生まれる
それところはもう一応分かったことにして
そこで我々に出てくるのは体の問題なんですね
私は認識することだけ見ると
全然このナノミリぐらいにも場所を要りませんね
認識することには 認識するという働きだから
例えば電気に 電気にはどれぐらい場所が必要ですかね
全然こんなに場所は要りませんね
エネルギーだからと つなげておくとか流れていくとか言えば
やっぱり流れる道を作ってあげなくちゃいけない
でも電線の太さと関係なく巨大な働きをしてくれるんでしょう？ですから
この認識機能には別に場所は要りません
要りませんだけど 私たちにはもうかなり大きな体がついてるんですね
この空いてる体の中で電気流れてるような感じであっちこっちあっちこっちで認識という働きを起こしている
そこでこの それから私たちに見えるのは
認識で認識できるのは
このいろんなものを私たちの認識を起こしていることなんですね
例えばラジオをつけていると
私はもう全く無力 無力でどうすることもできないんですね
ラジオから出てくる音によって
もうずっと認識が生まれっぱなしなんですね
ああ 嫌だなと思っても
それは止まるわけがないんですね
目が開けて 開けておくと
ものは見える 見える 見える
もうどうしようもないんですね
ということは 例えば私は目を開けている
それで人々はいろんなものを私の目の前に持ってくる
いろんなものを持ってくるたびに
私の心の変化が起こる
人を何か部屋に座らせて
もう椅子に座らせて 前何かちょっと穴を開けて
それに箱でも入れておいて
その人その目の前にいろんなものをいろんな物体を置いておいてみてください
植木鉢 植木鉢を置いておけば
それなりの認識が生まれる
ペンを置いておけばそれなりの認識が生まれてくる
そこでリンゴ 1個置いたらまた違う認識が生まれる
じゃあ認識が生まれないように頑張ってくださいったら
それ頑張ることはどうしようもできないんですね
全く無気力なんですね
自我意識はそこに働かない
自分というのはだからないんだと
だから魂はないということを仏教は徹底的に言うんですね
どうすることもできない
ただのエネルギーの流れであって
そこに私というものは全くないんだと
私というものがいるならば
私は植木鉢とリンゴは見るんだけど
あなたは次に虫を見せたんだと
次にヘビを見る それは見ませんと
認識しませんと ということは不可能だから
目の場合は目を閉じることできますけど
例えばこれは実験だから目を閉じな
閉じるなと 見せるものは全部見なさいと言っておいたならば
やっぱりヘビも見えちゃいますから
しょうがないんです あるいは実験室で我々はいろいろ音を出しますけど
それを適当に自分が好きな音だけ聞いてくださいと言ったって
そんなことできるわけじゃないし
あるいは私はこれからあなたを散々ぶん殴りますけど
決してあなたは痛みを感じないでくださいと思ったとしてもできないし
だからこの自我がなくて
私という何かなくて ただの物事のエネルギーの流れだけですということはもうとっくに言ってるんですね
だから宗教の立場から見れば
なんか嫌な話なんですね
すごく気持ちよく ありがたく喋るのは宗教の世界だからね
ありがたい仏様の話とありがたい極楽道の話とかね
ありがたい天国の話とかね
そういうふうなことを喋って
人々をね すごい衰弱させちゃって
死んでも極楽道に生まれるんではないか
そこでハスの花の上で
それまたすごい金で出来上がったハスの花で
そこで this is 化粧として生まれるんだとかね
言って 人間の欲の認識をどんどんどんどん増やすのは宗教の世界で
で 悟りの世界はもうそうではなくて
ちょっと恐ろしい すごいもう気が強いものの世界なんです
怖いものを知らないという感じで勉強しなきゃ
もう理解できないんです
だからもうこれは決してこの教務主義的な話でもないんです
きちんと法則の流れ エネルギーの流れはちゃんと知ってるんだから
自分がない ないんだけど
現象を積み重ねたところで自分という実感が生まれるということは言ってるだけ
いや それで問題はこの物体なんで
とにかく 認識がこの体の中で生まれる
外のものによっても認識が生まれる
それで心だけ分析して理解したっても
もうちょっと物足りないんだと認識を起こす
起こさせるというんですか
認識を起こさせる この物体の世界も考えなくちゃいけない
物質の世界ですから ルーパというのは物質の世界
物質って言ったっても
仏教ではこの物質とは最初からもうなんか見てないみたいですね
科学の世界ではちゃんとした物事はあるんだけど
仏教にはもうまたおかしいことに別にちゃんとした物事はないんですね
つまりエネルギーだと
変化するものだと 変化しなきゃ物質はもう認めないんですね
だからルーパという言葉入れているんですね
変化するんだからルーパですよと
例えば音が 音は物質です
仏教では 音があると言ったら
このスピーカーから音が出る
それからスピーカーからエネルギーを流れてこなきゃ耳まで
エネルギーが流れていくということは変化していくということなんですね
何か変化が起こらなきゃ
もう何も起こりませんということで
認識も起こりませんと
例えばスピーカーは何にも変化は起こしません
じゃあそこに音がありますか？そこに音がないんです
例えば 私の目の前で何か物体を持ってきたんだと
リンゴ 1個持ってきたんだと
そのリンゴは何にも変化を起こしませんならば見えない
リンゴはやっぱり光に反射するという働きでもしている
リンゴに光が当たったら
その光は変化するんですね
その変化は誰がさせたんですか？リンゴをさせたんですね
ですから 光はエネルギーであるならば
リンゴもエネルギーであるんでしょう
そうするとエネルギーにエネルギーがぶつかったところで違うエネルギーが生まれるということは
リンゴ自体も変化しているはずなんですね
光が当たっただけでも
そこで我々はリンゴというものが見えてしまう
だから変化しなきゃ 物質ではないということになるんですね
電気はありますかというと
電気っていうのは変化するんだったらあるんであって
そうでないと我々は電気だと違和感はないんですね
例えばこのメガネケースであっても同じものあるでしょうに
でもこちらには電気がないと言うんです
なぜならば 我々電気というものはこの中で変化は起こせませんだから
ですから これ触ってもこのメガネケース触っても電気ショックは受けません
でも電気というエレクトロンですか
この電子ですか この電線触ったらエレクトロンはもう流れて逃げていくんですね
そうすると我々は電気ショックを受ける
ですから 変化は仏教では大事
それは物理学的に見たっても物質はあるわけじゃなくて
このエネルギーとして物事は変化しているものに物質というだけ
なかなか難しいんですね
とにかくね まあそこで物質的なこの変化はどれぐらいありますか？ 28ありますね
28種類のすごい数少ない
その中でもほとんどまあしょうがないなと思って入れてるもので
別になくてもいい数なんです
28でなくてもいいんです
それ勉強するとわかるんですけど
本当に 28ありますかと物質は
いうと別に 28あるわけじゃないんです
まあみんな理解に苦しむんだから
まあしょうがないということで
まあ余計に入れてるんです
たくさんカットできます
ですから 物質もほんの数少ない物質っていうのはエネルギーですね
エネルギーも数少ない
結局はあるのは 4つだけなんです 4
種類のエネルギーの変化
流れを見て 我々は物質の世界を作っているんです
そこで仏教のルーパの勉強はどうなりますかというと
我々宇宙やらああだこうだと言ってる客観的な世界も消えちゃうんです
ただのエネルギーの変化で終わっちゃう
それ全部理解したところで 4番目の状態がわかるんです
で ニッバーナっていうのは涅槃ですね
いわゆるこのエネルギーとエネルギーをぶつかって認識というものが生まれて
それでまた また違うもの
そういうもうキリがなく流れていっちゃうんですね
じゃあそのまま流れ変えたらどうなるんですかというと
どうにもこうにも喋ることも何もできない世界になってしまっちゃうんです
例えばもう認識できるということがあって
でも認識できるということは言えません
だから何か認識しなきゃで認識すると
その認識することによって私は私がいるというだけで
そこで認識できるということがなくなったと
そこに私がいるんですかね
その私はどうなったんですかね
次の状態はどういう状態ですね
何も喋れませんでしょ
次の状態認識できない状態だから
だから何の言葉にも当てはまらない
何の存在の次元も当てはめない
何の理屈では考えられない
全てが理屈は終わると
全ての言語の世界が終わると
全ての体験の世界が終わると
このチッタとチェータシッカとルーパを理解する
それは全部現象の世界ですね
その現象の世界を理解してしまえば
全部乗り越えてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから それは涅槃と呼ぶんですね
ですから 一つしかないんですね
現象が消えた状態だから
これは一つしかない 大乗仏教はたくさんありますけど
たくさんそこでそれまですごい哲学的に迫ってると自分で自己を自慢してるんです
理屈が完全な理屈なの
現象消えたらそれそれでそれだけの状態だから
それにいろいろ段階やらね
あるはずがないんです
ですから 我々この初期仏教は小乗仏教になりませんだけど
そういう阿羅漢にならな
そんなことはもう完全な悟りじゃないんだとわかる
とにかく舎論でもやっぱりこのアサンカタアサンカタダンマというのは 3つぐらい考えているんですね
僕はその理屈は未だに分かってないんですね
なんで 3つ作ったかと
舎論はすごい実体論だからね
どうせテーラワーダのアビダンマとは違うし
まあそういうので一応その 4つで
もうまた正義隊のずっと繰り返しの講義でしたけど
だいたいそれぐらい 今日の講義も少々難しいかもしれません
で で これ終わってからこの
大体基本的にこの 4つ分かればそれだけの話なんです
アビダンマっていうのは
その 4つを理解することなんですね
その 4つの中でも これは理解しようとはしない
これの分析と解釈だけで終わっちゃうんですね
あの前の 3つチッタ チェータシッカ
ルーパ それの働き いろいろな形で理解することなんです
だからどれぐらい理解するかということは
そのその個人の好みで理解能力で決めるもので
ものすごく理解しなきゃいけすまないというならば
膨大なアビダンマ哲学はあるんですね
ここでテキストを使っているのは
このアビダンマで基本的に使う項目だけ
別に内容はないんです
この本の なんて言いますか
コンテンツ こういうこういうこういう項目ですよと
この前開けたら見えるでしょう
それだけのことなんです
で このテキストはアビダルマを勉強する人に
このどんな内容を勉強するのかと名前だけ覚えておく
名前を覚えておいたところで
別のアビダルマは存在しているんです
アビダルマの世界は ここで項目の定義だけを一章終わりますけど
別にこんなに膨大に勉強しなくてもいいんです
それなりにそれなりに
僕もまあちょっとまだ決まってないんです
きちんとやるか ただまあ六回八回ぐらいで
いくらか大雑把にアビダルマってそういうこういうものだよというふうに
なんとか一般的な理解で一般講義で終わるかということまで決まってないんです
とことんやろうと思うと
もう終われないんですね
どこかで手を打たないと
で 真理 そういう不思議な知恵なんですね
そんなに終わりきらないほどのものを勉強できるかというと
これできるということが不思議なんですね
やっぱり いくらか微かに理解しておけば
もういくらでも自分に次から次から次へと理解できてできてできてしまうんですね
いわゆるこの膨大な知恵に何かをパイプを作っておけばいいんです
そのパイプを通して この知識能力を自分が得るか得られないかというのは別な問題です
ですから この真理の世界に自分のパイプを繋げておくだけで十分なんです
全てを全てを知っている
知らなくちゃいけない
例えば 図書館に自分の名前を登録してもらってメンバーになっていれば
図書館のどんな本も読めるんですね
だからって片っ端からこの図書館の本を読まなきゃ
立派な図書館のメンバーにならないんだよということはないんです
一応会員にならなきゃ本が読めない
図書館にアクセスできない
ですから 僕が言うのはそういうぐらいで
この一応アクセスだけをしておきなさいと
そうすると自分に適当な知識だけ
それからダウンロードしてもらって
それで十分ですと ですから
一応このこの四つでも基本的なこのアクセス番号なんですね
この四つをまた二 三回でも講義で繰り返して繰り返して考えて理解すれば
もう自分にはもうアクセス番号はもらったことになっちゃうんですね
それから自分次第にいろいろ新しいこの命令コードを覚えちゃえば
覚えればそれなりのプログラムが出てくるということになっちゃうんですね
この四つは一応アビダルマの世界に基本的なアクセスコードなんですね
大体四時までですか？四時半までですか
四時 までですね 一応 3時間だったんですけど
これそっと聞くのはつらいんだから
もう一つ この忘れたことがあります
心は一つと言ったんですね
本当は一つですけど 一応
89種類にこの 分析ですか
分けてはいるんですね
89 本当は一つですが
一応 89ぐらいの種類は大雑把に分けられるということなんですね
その種類というのはどうやって 89 になるかというと
心に入る心象によるんですね
例えば 心に悪い心象入っちゃったら
怒りとか嫉妬とか その場合は悪い心だと
慈悲や慈しみとか何とか入っちゃったら
あ いい心だと分けちゃいますね
ですから そんなに厳密な分け方じゃないんです
また 基本的なことをアビダルマのまた紹介的な基本的なことをただ簡単にいろいろ喋りますけど
このアビダルマの狙いは
やっぱり人に何か大胆な膨大な知識を与えて人を驚かせてやろうということじゃないんです
我こそすごい知恵を持ってるんだよということを言うためじゃないんです
ただ いかに納得すれば心が清らかになるかと
人間はどうしても修行したくないんです
人間が悟りとか修行とかのことを言ってますけど
やっぱり得たくないんです
それは仏教だけの問題じゃないんです
他の宗教にしたっても
神様やら天国やとかいろんなことを言うんだけど
やっぱり実際に人間はもう神様のもうそっぽ向いて
もう自分勝手に生きてるんですね
例えば宗教でやってはいけない
やってはいけないということは
一生懸命人間というのはやってるんです
仏教では神様みたいに見張ってるこの見張り番がないんだから
みんな自由に悪いことをやってますけど
例えばキリスト教にしちゃったら
もうじっと神様は休みなく見ているんですね
それなのに やっぱりそういう人々は厳密に神様に従って生活していますかというと
全くないんですね ですから
それは人間の問題なんですね
人間がどんな人間でも
ある道で歩みたい もうちょっと知恵がある人から見れば
やっぱりその道がやめた方がいいと言うんですね
そのやめた方がいいと言っているのは宗教の世界なんですね
でも 人間はやっぱりそれに逆らって違う道に行きたいんですね
仏教も他の宗教も やっぱりその道はやめた方がいいんじゃないかと
一生懸命説教はする 説教はするんだけど
人は聞いてくれない 自分の道でやってしまっちゃうんですね
それも人間は本能として
その道はもう定めているような感じなんですね
いわゆる分かりやすく言えば
堕落の道と言ってもいいし
堕落の道に行くようにも定められているような状態なんですね
何も言わなくたっても
人は悪くはなるんです
でも 人を良くするためには一生懸命苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
どんな努力なくても人は悪くなってしまっちゃうんです
そういう心理あるんですね
法則があるんですね それでイエス様にしても
やっぱり司会するなと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
司会するのは良くないんだと言っても
イエス様が言うことを信じますよ
神様も信じますよと言いながらも
キリスト教の人々もやっぱりすぐ司会してたり
嫉妬したりはするんですね
この問題という これ矛盾ではないんだけど
何言えばいいかわかりませんね
我々にもこの生きるべき生きるべき道があって
生きたい道があってとか
行かなくちゃいけない道があって
どうしても生きたい道があるんだと
2つなんですね そこで宗教の世界はいろいろ工夫するんです
わかりやすいキリスト教から言えば
この最後の審判が出てくるんだと
その時は片っ端から神は裁きを下すんだと
言って脅しをするんですね
脅したりでもして 人は自分で本能で生きてる道をなんとかしましょうと思ってるんですね
で ヒンドゥー教などまた違うことを言ったりしたり
で 仏教の場合はより難しいんですね
問題は キリスト教の場合はえらい巨大妄想で
この神という妄想を使ってるんだから
あの やり 脅しやすいんだけど
仏教でそういう妄想 いわゆる偉大なる支配者がいませんだから
生命一人一人別々ですから
独立してるんだから 親分がいないんです
そうするともっと仏教だけなんですね
この問題に本当に出会ったのは
どうやって人々は正しい道に引っ張るかということは
仏教はもうああいう親分を否定
もう否定 否定しているんではなくて
この成り立たないと言ってるんだから
そういうことで この脅しの代わりにとことんこの心理の姿
我々の心はどう働いているんですかと
どういうふうに働いたらどんな結果になるかと
それは科学的な目でとことん納得させようとする
この心理の状態をよく納得したら
この自分の道っていうのはすごくバカバカらしく見えちゃうんですね
この欲の道 快楽の道 知識を目指していく道
知識 名誉 財産ありとあらゆるものを目指して
で 頑張ってる道はバカバカらしく見えちゃうんですね
嫌になっちゃうんですね
そうするとこの本能的に嫌になっちゃうんだから
自分の意志でやっぱり正しい道を歩んでみよう
励まして励んでみようという
この気持ちが生まれる
その気持ちが生まれてくるためにあるんです
仏道を励んで励むのはいいんだと
この本物の自分の気持ちを生むためなんです
ただそれだけのためにすごい苦労しているんです
ですから これ勉強したっても
修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
結局は それでわかるんです
よくわかりましたと よく納得いきましたと
これで納得いったら ものすごい強烈な人間にはなります
どんなものにも もう 何て言いますか
左右されないというか
誘惑されないというふうな
しっかりした知恵は生まれますよ
生まれるんだけど やっぱり煩悩を断つためには
もう次にまた実践に入らなくちゃいけない
ですから いわゆるこの修行に人を
あの 励ましてあげるための哲学なんですけど
それまた勉強するとみんな逃げてしまう
[笑い]あまりにもややこしくて難しくて逃げてしまうこともあるんです
それからこのだからちょっとこのアビダンマではものすごい欠陥があるんです
アビダンマ自体はこの私の私見なんですけど
完璧な哲学じゃないんです
完璧な心理学じゃないんです
欠陥だらけの哲学で欠陥だらけの心理学なんです
その欠陥はどちらに これお坊さんたちは絶対言わないことですけど
ミャンマーのお坊さんに分かったらもう私のことをどうするかわからないので
すごい怖いんだけど でもこの欠陥はどういうふうに生まれたかというと
このアビダンマの目的はこの
まず修行する気持ちを起こすために
それから修行の過程において
自分の心はどう理解してどう進むかと
その説明なんですね ですから
結局アビダンマというのは解脱に必要な心理学
解脱に必要な哲学 解脱に必要な論理なんですね
だから普通の俗の俗世界にはあんまり関係ないんですね
俗世界のことはそんなに気にしてない
どうやって商売繁盛するかとかね
もう問題にしてないんですね
どうやって対人関係をうまくするんですかとかね
そんなものは問題にならない
すごいバカバカらしいゴミの話になってるんですね
対人関係 何のために必要ですかと
何のために商売繁盛ですかと
何のために家族なんとか何とかですかと
と聞きたくなっちゃうんですね
それもその人々はこの認識にやられて
いい認識を作りたく いわゆるちょっとした採算が合えたところで喜びを味わって
その喜びをさらにさらに味わいたく
物に依存している 喜びは心に生まれたもので
勝手に生まれたもんだから
いくらでも勝手に喜びを心に作ればいいでしょうに
例えば万円儲かったところで
ある人はものすごく喜んだと
そのある人は万円儲かった
ああ やっぱり万円かと
すごい不満を感じちゃうでしょ
ですから万円を剃って不満を感じる
万円を持って究極の喜びを感じるというのは
その二人の心次第ですから
決して万円のせいじゃないんです
それをわかってないんですね
みんな だからやっぱり金儲ければ幸福だと
商売繁盛は幸福だとすごい誤解しているんですね
だから喜びも苦しみも悲しみも悩みも
心の持ち方次第で勝手に生まれるものなんですね
ですから 喜びたければ万円がなくても
円なくても究極的にいくらでも喜べる
悔しがりたければ 何のものがなくたっていつでも悔しくなることできるんです
いくらでも その心の働きが危ないんだから
そこら辺は何とかしてあげようと
別に商売繁盛のための心理学はない
家庭安全のための心理学はアビダンマではない
精神分裂病の患者さんを治るために心理学はない
そんなものは我々から見れば
もうあまりにも俗的で
あまりにも低次元で 心理学とも言えないほどのものなんです
仏教の心理学っていうのは
普通の知識人が普通にノーマルな人々がどうやって優れた人間になるかと
どうやって存在そのものを乗り越えるかと
この存在という実感乗り越えるために必要な大変難しい心の過程ですか
そこを分析するためにあるものだから
もうどうせ人間の知識にはもう敵わない心理学なんですね
それは僕は欠陥だと言っているところなんですね
心理学と見れば まあごく普通にいろいろ役に立つようなものでなければいけませんし
あるいは心の分析というならば
ごく普通の人間の心の分析もあってほしいんだけど
そういうところは全部カット
物質の分析にしたっても
もういろんな物質の分析ね
科学的に何か役に立つものを作るというか
役に立つ説明とかあっても悪くはないんだけど
それは全部カット 単なる素粒子論だけで終わっちゃう
例えば心からいろんな物質が生まれますと言うんです
言うんだけど それだったら心をコントロールして
いろんな物質を作ってしまえば
すごい気持ちいいもんでしょうね
自分の心で自分の好きなものを作ってしまっちゃうんだと
それはカット教えてあげないと
その代わりに心によって物質が生まれるんだと
心によって客観的な社会が生まれるんだと
大体こういうこういうふうに生まれるんだと言って
そこで終わるんですね
ですから 我々の俗的な目で聞きたがっているものは言ってない
その代わりに解脱に必要なものだけ言ってるんです
ですから あくまでもアビダンマ論というのは修行者のために必要な論理性ですね
ですから 純粋な仏典ではないんです
それはお坊さんたちが作ったものなんです